Miami is back famously decimated in the
housing process the real estate market
is now booming and these are the brokers
selling Miami the jill's together these
two had over half a billion dollars in
sales last year we're seeing prices that
we have not really seen before but in
the last few years starting with the
sale and indeed brief island for 47
million all of a sudden that started
lifting the market up boom to bust to
recovery
Miami property prices are now leading
the nation but doesn't history repeat
itself the housing crisis was just a few
years ago and Miami was at the epicenter
of it before they had zero income
verification you could put down five
percent right now all these new
constructions they're asking 50 percent
down so you're gonna really think twice
before you walk away on a substantial
unit the people that we are dealing with
are really almost a hundred percent
all-cash buyers foreigners made up 60
percent of Miami's total sales last year
but now US buyers are also ponying up
and what's driving Florida is not only
the baby boom generation but high taxes
I mean I think you seem to reach the
inflection point of North the hedge fund
managers you see them increasingly
coming down here and thinking about
setting up shop to meet demand developer
Barry sterling is spending 300 million
dollars to transform the former
Gansevoort hotel into one hotel and
homes
I think Miami's the Singapore of the
United States the property will have 417
hotel rooms and 163 for sale condos at
prices of 220 million dollars beautiful
right it's gorgeous
I just can't believe people have any
money that's the great danger is
interest rates rising because a lot of
people are borrowing to buy residences
but you're not worried about rates
rising not for the next two years
Hotel er Ian Schrager also sees value in
Miami he's opened his first hotel since
the Delano nearly two decades of them
it's a more mature place in the cycle
for the development of my habit
formerly the Seville hotel shraeger 's
Edition sits on three and a half acres
and features 294 rooms and 26 residences
there's too many fundamentally
attractive things and attributes that
Miami has it's good to be above them I
see nothing but growth